final question it comes from uh anav
from our telegram Community what lessons
have you learned from running Pizza
pilgrims that you could share with
aspiring entrepreneurs I I think you
know it's such a cliche thing but like
no one no one knows what they're doing
like especially in restaurants so don't
overthink it like if you've got an idea
and you like it think of any way you can
test it that you know will give you a
bit more insight into where the idea is
is a goer whether you actually enjoy it
whether it's something that's you know
there's a need for it without quitting
your job so you don't have to like throw
over thing in on day one just start
testing the fences a little bit but the
other thing is don't go away to my mind
like you know I could have gone right I
want to run a pizza company what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go and work
for Pizza Express for 10 years and
figure out exactly how they do
everything and then I can go away and
and I don't think that would have set me
up any more to for Success than just
having a crack and doing it your
way